-Guys, do you ever see a photo in the news and think
the headline could be much better than the photo?
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "News & Improved." Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-Thank you, Roots.
For example, check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
The headline can definitely be improved
because if you only looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
-Oh.
-"Oh, my -- Golly gee!"
Check out this next photo.
The original headline was...
If you only looked at the photo, the headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"I'm good. I'm good. I'm good. Oh!"
-Driving?
-Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"I'm just -- I'm just noticing you haven't..."
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"What happens in here?" -Oh, my God.
-You ever been in those? What happens?
You wash your hands, and people just flick?
-There's no towel. There's no nothing.
-It's just a disaster.
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Ohh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't tell the kids.
Blblblblb! Blblblblb!
Help-blblblblb!
[ Imitates toilet flush ]
-Uh... this next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
"All the beef you want."
-"Beefy quesadilla, right?"
-It's a double "beef" que--
-It's a double "beef," man.
-Dude, we have all the 'beef' you want to put in one taco.
-Wait. Why are you doing this? Why's --
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"Yeah. Chill it out, dude."
-Oi!
-"Calm it down." -"There's a goldfish in there."
-"Yeah, there's a goldfish in there."
[ Laughter ]
Wow! -He needs to drink more water.
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"I'm leaving Dad!"
Finally, this headline was...
Headline could have been...
There you go.
That's all the time we have for "News & Improved."